[Musique]
avec voilà une phrase bien sûr bonjour
hélène bonjour pauline et donc à la une
de la presse ces heurts en marge de la
mobilisation anti vaccins en nouvelle
zélande ont évoqué le canada à l'instant
où des manifestants sont installés
depuis trois jours près du parlement à
wellington ces manifestations inspirées
effectivement du convoi a dit de la
liberté d'ottawa au canada ont pris un
tour violent selon de presse qui fait
état d'une cinquantaine d'arrestations
cette nuit end prochain sous pression de
new zealand herald rapporte que les
manifestants ont notamment proféré des
menaces contre les médias présents sur
place des manifestants qui ont également
mis en garde contre je les cite la
possibilité d'une troisième guerre
mondiale ont dit craindre que la
nouvelle zélande devienne un état
communiste est totalitaire ou encore
menacée je les cite toujours de pendre
haut et court les partisans de
l'obligation vaccinale
d'après le dominion post ses dérapages
verbaux sont en train de faire basculer
l'opinion des néo-zélandais qui sont
choqués par ces outrances et le journal
présente lui c'est anti vaccins comme
une émanation de la droite populiste
américaine de ces allégations
complotistes infondées et de sa
rhétorique appelant à la violence en
france les opposants l'a vu en tilt axa
et ou aux mesures de sanitaires se
prépare également à manifester nice
matin fait état du départ hier d'un
convoi de la liberté depuis la côte
d'azur et le var direction paris samedi
puis bruxelles lundi une mobilisation au
slogan complotistes mais également anti
macro nist selon le journal emmanuel
macron a toujours candidat officieux à
sa réélection mais qui engrange déjà des
ralliements dernière en date l'ancien
ministre et fidèle de nicolas sarkozy
eric woerth un coup dur pour la
candidate des républicains valérie
pécresse selon le parisien aujourd'hui
en france auquel l'actuel président l
ère de la commission des finances à
l'assemblée a justifié son choix la
france a besoin d'un président
expérimenté je le cite le ralliement
d'eric woerth augure-t-il d'un soutien
au futur soutien de colas sarkozy à
emmanuel macron sa une le sait mais à
droite le silence de l'ancien président
commencerait à inquiéter sérieusement
l'entourage de valérie pécresse d'après
le figaro qui cite pauline cette
déclaration ma foi peu amènes de l'ex
chef de l'état sur la candidate elle se
dit chiraquienne a très bien mais qui
l'a fait ministre pendant cinq ans c'est
chirac
les candidats à la présidentielle
interpellé par la presse ce matin hélène
sur l'utilisation des super profits des
entreprises du cac 40 alors que les plus
grandes entreprises françaises on le
sait affiche des résultats records le
débat sur ces supers profits et relancé
en loi par la croix qui cite l'appel du
patron de la ces pme le président de la
conférence de la confédération des
petites et moyennes entreprises françois
à cela plaide pour exonérer d'impôt sur
les sociétés
les entreprises qui ne distribuent pas
de dividendes on partage libération
rappelle que les entreprises du cac 40
ont été largement aidée par l'état
durant la crise et qu'elles ont
majoritairement remercier c'est super
profits au seul actionnaire libé propose
lui que ses profits soient partagées
équitablement entre actionnaires et
salariés
la différence de traitement entre les
uns et les autres étant considéré comme
éminemment dangereuse car elle accroît
davantage les inégalités et créer du
ressentiment si ce n'est de la colère le
ressentiment et la colère pour le cours
au royaume uni on en parle souvent vous
et moi ilan ici-même longue de choc du
parti gates et fête organisée à d'un
district pendant le confinant le
confinement et ça continue de se
propager de plus un mort ne fait pas un
jour sans nouvelles révélations pas un
jour sans clichés compromettants dernier
en date une photo de ben jonson
débraillé lors d'une soirée arrosée au
procès qu c'était en janvier 2021 ce
cliché fait-il partie des quelque 300
images transmises aux autorités par sur
grêle une haute fonctionnaire qui a
rédigé un rapport accablant sur ces
sauteries à downing street ça en
l'ignorent mais le gratuit métro affirme
que scotland yard dispose d'une autre
photo montrant boju immortaliser à la
main lors d'une fête d'anniversaire en
juin 2020 un cliché pris par le
photographe officiel du premier ministre
c'est à dire payer par le contribuable
c'est dans ce contexte pour le moins
compliqué que le premier ministre a
annoncé hier qu'il allait mettre un
terme à toutes les restrictions
sanitaires dès le 24 février prochain si
les détracteurs de bozo le clown voient
dans cette annonce une tentative de
diversion et bien le daily mail on le
voit salue la nouvelle en claironnant
que le royaume uni talent devient la
première grande nation au monde a laissé
derrière elle la pandémie je cite bien
sûr on skie pas là dessus elle à chacun
son clown aux états unis c'est l'élu
trump heist majorité l'organe qui s'est
illustré mardi en comparant la prison où
sont détenus les assaillants du capitole
au goulag soviétique et en présentant
ces manifestants comme des victimes je
la cite de la police gaspacho de nancy
pelosi la chef démocrate du congrès
cette confusion entre la police
politique nazie la gestapo et le potage
espagnol le gaspacho a bien sûr
déclencher les railleries des
internautes le plus inspiré sans doute
étant celui qui vous propose pauline de
choisir votre soupe répressive préféré
le gaspacho d'hitler ou le goulasch
douce câline
calamiteux au pathétique et l'annoncé
pas merci beaucoup c'était la revue de
presse on vous retrouve aux alentours de
9h20 d'emparé direct nom se retrouve
dans un instant pour le journal de 7h30
avec pauline godard
[Musique]